[Música]
la volatilidad política sigue siendo la
constante en Perú son varios los
escándalos que han rodeado al presidente
Pedro Castillo a su gobierno a sus
funcionarios y hasta a sus propios
familiares el mandatario ha reiterado
que está seguidilla de escándalos de
emociones de censura etcétera hacen
parte de un intento por sacarlo del
poder por parte de la oposición según el
mandatario también de la fiscalía y de
otros organismos del Estado la
Organización de Estados Americanos la
oea aprobó una resolución de apoyo al
gobierno que pidió preservar la
institucionalidad democrática tanto Perú
como América Latina pues claramente no
se pueden acostumbrar a estas crisis
interminables sobre todo en este país
suramericano porque las consecuencias
van más allá de las fronteras peruanas
un país en crisis en nuestra región
refuerza la volatilidad política que ya
se puede decir hace parte del
funcionamiento de los estados de América
Latina la estabilidad política de Perú
importa y nos importa mucho veamos más
detalles en el siguiente informe
por aclamación la Organización de
Estados Americanos aprobó en sesión
extraordinaria atender la petición del
gobierno de Perú
expresar su solidaridad y respaldo al
gobierno democráticamente electo de la
República de Perú así como la
preservación de la institucionalidad
democrática entre las medidas aprobadas
el organismo enviará una delegación de
alto nivel a Perú para que pueda
analizar la situación del país así lo
anunció la cancillería en Twitter en
estricto respecto del derecho
internacional el principio de no
intervención y la solidaridad de
hemisférica y consejo permanente
resolvió Designar un grupo de alto nivel
conformado por representantes de
diversos estados miembro Pero ha
obtenido el respaldo de los países
vecinos en plena ola de gobiernos de
izquierda en América Latina Mientras que
el miércoles la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos señaló que el uso
reiterado de figuras constitucionales
como la vacancia generan que desde 2016
el país haya tenido cinco presidentes y
tres parlamentos también el miércoles el
gobierno de Pedro Castillo en un
discurso televisado negó las acusaciones
de la fiscalía denuncia inconstitucional
e ilegal sin fundamentos y que carece de
toda corroboración y pruebas objetivas
la pasada semana la fiscalía presentó
una denuncia constitucional en contra
del presidente al que acusa de ser el
líder de una organización criminal pero
la Constitución según el artículo 117 no
permite procesar al presidente por
corrupción o delitos comunes
está Perú entonces en una crisis
perpetua Ese es nuestro tema de análisis
hoy en el debate de France 24 y para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a Elizabeth sea ella es directora del
instituto de derechos humanos y
desarrollo ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de Lina de Lima y también está
con nosotros José Carlos requena Él es
analista político socio de la consultora
público también es columnista del diario
el comercio y también se encuentra en la
capital peruana en la Ciudad de Lima a
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también son parte de este debate pueden
dejar sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook también nos
encuentran en instagram no se encuentran
como arroba el debate_f24 y arroba
santílogo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
f24 todo pegado para que dejen ustedes
sus comentarios no olviden también que
en nuestros contenidos también están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas de
podcast nos encuentran en Apple podcast
en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Elizabeth Elizabeth Gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en el programa y
nuestro Punto de partida como lo decía
como lo dice en nuestra promo y como lo
decía Hace algunos minutos pero parece
estar en una crisis perpetua el
presidente actual lento cuando tiene que
tomar decisiones no cuenta con la
confianza suficiente por parte de los
instituciones y de los ciudadanos y el
congreso y la oposición tampoco le hacen
fácil el camino
bueno de todo muchas gracias por la
invitación efectivamente nuestro país
viene no recientemente con el gobierno
de Castillo hay que decirlo tenemos
bastantes años no décadas digamos en
este conflicto político entre
las fuerzas y oposición y los gobiernos
que están en el poder
sin embargo hay que decir que
los gobiernos anteriores ya han estado
en cursos en investigaciones Fiscales y
han enfrentado la justicia sin embargo
en este momento se trata de
investigaciones
en las cuales está incursa el señor el
presidente Pedro Castillo y su entorno
más allegado entre ellos sus familiares
sus asesores más próximos o ex asesores
más próximos y ministros de estado
Y definitivamente Aquí hay una hay una
lucha perenne no entre el congreso y El
Ejecutivo por un lado el congreso
tratando de realizar su labor de
fiscalización y de control político con
el poder ejecutivo un poder ejecutivo
que no hace mea culpa un poder ejecutivo
que no acepta que esté siendo
investigado que dice que el hecho de
este incurso en una demanda de acusación
constitucional es algo inconstitucional
cuando Esto no es así en tanto esto se
está dando al Amparo de la constitución
de nuestro país y del reglamento del
Congreso permítanme decirlo también
Entonces definitivamente esta crisis
Lamentablemente está impactando en la
ciudadanía y sobre todo en las personas
más vulnerables que lo que esperan es
que exista pues una real digamos
la bendición de cuentas por parte del
gobierno como debe de ser afín al
principio de transparencia no
ahora le doy la palabra a Juan Carlos en
nuestro siguiente invitado también para
conocer sus opiniones y sus puntos de
vista El Punto de partida Juan Carlos
Bienvenido al programa pero en una
crisis perpetua no es solamente ahora
con el presidente Castillo como lo
estaba diciendo Elizabeth aquí en
francés 24 le hemos hecho seguimiento a
la situación política y a este espiral
de crisis y hemos visto la cantidad de
gobiernos que han pasado la cantidad de
ministros que han pasado por el
escenario político también de congresos
elecciones
Y esto no termina
sí José Carlos
ante una crisis que se va haciendo
Crónica en este coincido con Elizabeth
en que está digamos es una seguiría yo
creo que hemos centrado en una situación
así por lo menos desde el año 2017 en
que se aplicó por primera vez o se trató
de aplicar la lactancia presencial en el
caso de perobalo kuczynski En ese
entonces Y la verdad Lamentablemente ha
perdido estilo esta figura
constitucional y que creo yo era digamos
el momento en el que estamos era
Precisamente lo que podía habernos
servido de una válvula de escape porque
aunque el presidente insiste en esta
victimización que con la que también ha
logrado que la oea vaya intervenir en
breve
En realidad estamos en una situación
absolutamente inédita el presidente en
funciones
está siendo acusado con bastantes
evidencias
la verdad bastante consistentes Entonces
cómo salimos de esta crisis y yo creo
que es Es imposible llegar a este estado
de vida lobo y que al que el presidente
aspira y con las condiciones que él
mismo ha estipulado la verdad casi desde
el inicio de su mandato es decir esta
seguidilla de ministros y no tiene que
ver con un acoso de la oposición tiene
que ver con el nombramiento inadecuado
de alto funcionarios de hecho el fin de
semana hemos presenciado un nuevo
escándalo de corrupción al interior del
gobierno y que de nuevo seguramente la
oposición Y algún sector de la oposición
puede tener alguna agenda
digamos que desconozcan los resultados
de las elecciones pero en general Yo
diría que el principal
causante de toda esta situación sigue
siendo El Ejecutivo sí José Carlos hago
la corrección José Carlos continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda a la inversa
citó un titular de la revista the
economist lo han publicado recientemente
y el título del artículo Tal vez es un
poco fuerte pero quiero conocer Qué
opinión tiene usted sobre sobre esta
aproximación Que ellos hacen y ellos
titulan Perú tiene un presidente
incompetente y un congreso completamente
desacreditado es este el escenario
político de Perú
Sí precisamente Y eso hace que la verdad
frente a lo que podría hacer una
solución constitucional Y como por
ejemplo el que se va que el presidente
castillo y que la vicepresidenta
concluya su mandato
esto también parece por lo menos en el
papel y si uno seguía solamente por las
encuestas de opinión parece algo
insostenible no yo creo que la principal
demanda Y en esto creo que incluye a
sectores de derecha y de izquierda
liberales conservadores es esta
expectativa por comienzos adelantados no
cómo evitamos eso es ese arte que la
clase política todavía no encontraba la
salida lamentablemente no ha encontrado
la salida Elizabeth Entonces cómo puede
empezar a articularse una posible salida
a la crisis cuando hay poca confianza en
la institucionalidad en el congreso
citando de nuevo esta revista día
economistas está completamente
desacreditado los peruanos tampoco
confían en los parlamentarios y en los
procesos que han llevado adelante a lo
largo de las últimas semanas o por lo
menos de estos 14 meses de gobierno de
castillo y el presidente Castillo
tampoco actúa lo que ha hecho es
prácticamente luchar por protegerse y
mantenerse en el poder pero poco a
gobernado
bueno Lamentablemente tenemos un
congreso que está compuesto por fuerzas
atomizadas y definitivamente eso
definitivamente marca la agenda política
en cuanto a poder emprender de una
manera correcta con estas herramientas
constitucionales que tiene el congreso
Como por ejemplo la vacacia presidencial
en ese momento se ha emprendido la
obtención de las firmas de la que
vendría a ser la tercera moción de
vacancia presidencial y hasta este
momento no se tienen Pues digamos si
bien se tienen ya las las firmas para
presentar la moción de acuerdo a lo que
se va viendo no se tendrían las 87
firmas que se necesitan pues para bajar
al presidente por incapacidad moral
en tanto como bien dices tenemos Pues un
congreso que también está integrado por
congresistas que han demostrado durante
el ejercicio de lo que vale el ejercicio
de su cargo definitivamente una un
compromiso con sus intereses personales
como es el caso de los niños no que que
son varios en el congreso y que incluso
han estado integrando la su comisión de
acusaciones constitucionales entonces
frente a este escenario no donde tenemos
Pues un poder legislativo que tendría
que hacer el contrapeso a un poder como
el poder ejecutivo que no está rindiendo
cuenta de sus actos un poder ejecutivo
que le rehuye a la investigación fiscal
porque ojo la Constitución no impide que
se le investigue no puede ser
investigado por lo tanto me parece a mí
de que si es que hay que hablar de
posibles salidas Yo pienso que aquí el
congreso no puede rehuir a su
responsabilidad de realizar este control
de convencionalidad sobre las normas
sobre que esta responsabilidad que tiene
que le ha dado la Constitución y los
tratados internacionales suscritos en
materia de lucha contra la corrupción
para que pueda emprender de una vez por
todas una salida democrática que las hay
las hay en nuestra Constitución Más allá
de la vacancia está el tema de la
acusación constitucional también se ha
dado también esta figura de aplicar
artículo 114 de la suspensión temporal
por incapacidad también moral del
presidente
diversos escenarios que el congreso
debería tomar la responsabilidad de
comenzar ya a evaluar cuál podría ser el
camino sin mirar sus intereses
personales que hasta este momento al
parecer están primando por sobre la
institucionalidad democrática en nuestro
país y el costo político que eso puede
representar para los diferentes
integrantes del Congreso y para sus
bancadas políticas Tal parece que
ninguna bancada quiere dar ese primer
paso para llegar a ese escenario que
usted propone Elizabeth continuó con
usted para hacer otra vez la ronda la
inversa y nos vamos ahora desde el lado
del presidente del lado del presidente
Castillo ha dicho en diferentes
ocasiones que el congreso y también la
oposición lo que han intentado hacer y
también la fiscalía recientemente han
intentado es realizar un golpe de estado
estas declaraciones son fuertes sobre
todo cuando uno no presenta pruebas
contundentes de estas afirmaciones que
está haciendo el jefe de estado allí en
Perú esto Qué significa para la
democracia peruana para esta misma
crisis política que viene presentando el
país que el presidente haga estas
afirmaciones no presente ningún tipo de
pruebas o por lo menos hasta el momento
no las ha presentado y lo deje
simplemente anunciado y y hasta ahí
llega no se actúa de ninguna manera
sí efectivamente bueno en primer lugar
lo que dice el presidente castillos
completamente
irreal porque como he repetido la
esta facultad que tiene la fiscal de la
nación de presentar una demanda de
acusación constitucional ojo no está
acusando el presidente está presentando
una demanda lo cual Está conforme la
Constitución y el reglamento del
Congreso
y lo hace fundamentado en seis carpetas
Fiscales de investigación que se vienen
implementando desde hace bastante tiempo
en el cual Pues hay indicios
contundentes contra el presidente y su
entorno Entonces definitivamente el
presidente está faltando a la verdad y
lo que está haciendo al decir y afirmar
eso
invocando inclusive a un organismo
internacional
está faltando a un deber que la misma
carta democrática señala que es el deber
de transparencia de todos los gobiernos
que esa fin a la democracia la misma
carta lo menciona y sin embargo Pues el
señor Castillo se ha olvidado de que
este es un deber que él le debe al país
justamente para ser prevalecer la
institucionalidad y la democracia
Entonces definitivamente aquí lo que se
está tratando de hacer es inducir a un
error a un organismo internacional que
estoy segura que en esta comisión de
alto nivel que ya está por venir al Perú
y se va a poder entrevistar con todas
las fuerzas
políticas pero también con los
instituciones y los poderes del Estado
la sociedad civil podrá darse cuenta que
lo que se quiere aquí es una demanda de
transparencia lo que está pidiendo la
ciudadanía peruana es que el presidente
respete dos derechos humanos para
nosotros fundamentales en la democracia
que son nuestro derecho a la verdad
y nuestro derecho de acceso a la
información pública reconocidas y
desarrolladas también por nuestro
tribunal constitucional derechos que el
señor no habla y que no se ha mencionado
todavía y que estoy y yo espero que
ahora cuando venga el organismo y cuando
venga la oea su comisión de alto nivel
puedan ellos darse cuenta que realmente
aquí lo que se está tratando de hacer es
que el gobierno rinda cuentas le dé cara
al país y que el presidente opte por la
salida más democrática que es renunciar
para mí lo más democrático es que él
renuncia de un paso al costado y pueda
dar
inicio a las investigaciones Fiscales
que se tengan que hacer Elizabeth ya
vamos a analizar ese tema de de la carta
democrática Y esa delegación que va a
llegar de la ONU a la Ciudad de Lima
quiero darle la palabra José Carlos para
analizar Tres puntos que usted menciona
Elizabeth que son esta falta de verdad
por parte del presidente no presentar
pruebas y este posible escenario de una
renuncia como no un paso democrático
para empezar a solucionar la crisis Cuál
es su opinión José Carlos
bueno Y yo coincido con con Elizabeth en
esta falta de La verdad la verdad el
presidente ha tenido como principal
agenda de estos últimos meses sobrevivir
y en el camino a removido a funcionarios
como incluyendo un ministro de interior
o un procurador del Estado básicamente
digamos con con grandes signos de
arbitrariedad no en el caso del ministro
del interior Mariano González puede solo
15 días en el cargo no hubo ninguna
razón Valera para removerlo era
simplemente que el ministro había
empezado a hacer su trabajo y creo que
esas son cosas que deben deben deben
señalarse con con bastante precisión no
no hay efectivamente pruebas de lo que
el presidente dice Lamentablemente la
palabra golpe se ha utilizado con mucha
ligereza en coyunturas también pasadas y
en cuanto a la renuncia a la verdad
Lamentablemente coincidiendo con
Elizabeth en que es la salida más limpia
ves algo que ya aparece poco probable
porque a estas alturas creo que el
presidente ya hubiera si su interés
preservará en que su nombre digamos
mantuviera algo de decoro pues ya ya
hubiera renunciado hace hace mucho no lo
ha hecho y yo creo que ese camino es muy
poco probable siendo si coincidiendo
siendo lo más lindo no no solamente el
presidente también varios políticos
peruanos que deberían tener un poco de
grandeza a nivel político justamente dar
un paso al costado precisamente para
ayudar a destrabar esta crisis Elizabeth
Juan José Carlos me gustaría que
escaláramos esto un poco más arriba ya
lo estamos analizando desde el ámbito
interno de lo que se ve allí en el día a
día en Perú pasemos lo un poco más a la
región lo decía yo en la introducción
del programa un Perú inestable con esta
volatilidad política estos cambios de
gobierno y toda esta seguidilla de
escándalos en solamente 14 meses de no
tiene un impacto no solamente para este
país sino también para la región Cómo
afecta esta crisis política de Perú esta
inestabilidad esta falta de dar pasos en
la dirección correcta para destrabar la
crisis para el resto de la región que
tampoco brilla por su estabilidad
política también lo decía yo en la
introducción le doy la palabra José
Carlos
bueno sin duda es un presidente muy muy
negativo para la región no
Lamentablemente los comicios del año 21
mostraron a un país que en el que
incluso la elección de Pedro Castillo
siendo el candidato menos calificado con
menos credenciales profesionales con
menos preparación con un programa más
radical el más radical de cualquiera de
los que se pudiera ver en la campaña y
ya el hecho de estar listos o de que un
país esté dispuesto a elegir a alguien
como Pedro Castillo te habla de algo que
está fallando no ese eso eso es en el
caso peruano otros países han
solucionado sus crisis de manera Digamos
si quieres un poco más canalizada No
necesariamente con con buenos resultados
pero con menos sobresaltos nosotros como
que nos hemos optado o nuestra situación
Más bien es como de una latencia que ya
este este y que no se vaya a solucionar
pero creo que como digamos como dominó o
como un núcleo de inestabilidad creo que
es un presidente bien bien complicado no
y por los presidentes que puede que
puede significar en sobre todo en los
sistemas presidencialistas algunos de
estos mecanismos que se están
discutiendo creo que una preocupación de
algunos constitucionalistas era el
presidente que podía formar de hecho en
los últimos cinco años hemos visto
muchos precedentes negativos como la
disolución del Congreso el año 19
que la verdad reduce o hacen que la
institucionalidad sea aún más precaria
Elizabeth su opinión
Sí bueno efectivamente coincido también
con José Carlos en su análisis Pero
además también particularmente a mí me
preocupa esta esta imagen que el Perú
pueda tener a nivel internacional y que
eso pueda perjudicar también las
inversiones en mi país que esto pueda
perjudicar también las relaciones
internacionales que o las pretensiones
por ejemplo de nuestro país de
pertenecer a la ocde
definitivamente aquí hay que pensar de
que el impacto de la crisis política
también se ve reflejada en una crisis
económica a gran escala que puede
perjudicar también
importantes actividades económicas que
dependen justamente de esas inversiones
extranjeras de la imagen que viven de la
imagen también económica frente al mundo
ya estamos viendo como algunas agencias
financieras económicas están bajándole
la calificación al Perú y esto también
preocupa porque aquí estamos pues en una
situación económica donde todo está
subiendo donde no existe Pues un digamos
una expectativa de vida o de calidad de
vida sobre todo para las personas en una
en situación de vulnerabilidad los
peruanos hemos ingresado en una
situación de pobreza y pobreza extrema
tras la pandemia y se entendía de
acuerdo a las promesas políticas el
señor Castillo que con un gobierno del
pueblo para el pueblo ellos iban a ser
los primeros en su agenda pública
emprender obras de infraestructura a
favor de estas de estas de estas
poblaciones no solucionar la
conflictividad social que en vez de ir
en descenso ha ido en aumento en su
gobierno y no lo ha cumplido Entonces
definitivamente es preocupante es
preocupante porque si nosotros miramos
la situación política en el impacto a
los derechos de las personas y la
economía pues definitivamente no estamos
en el mejor escenario y esto puede puede
prolongar digamos esta agonía también en
nuestro país no para solucionar esta
crisis yo añado Elizabeth y José Carlos
que el impacto que esto tiene es a todo
nivel no solamente a nivel interno
económico Social es a todo nivel Esto
está afectando las diferentes instancias
que componen el estado y el desarrollo
político social económico que tiene y
que necesita Perú en este momento escalo
esto un poco más arriba y voy ahora
referirme a ese pedido que hizo el
presidente Castillo a la Organización de
Estados Americanos para activar la carta
democrática el consejo permanente de
esta organización internacional o
continental ya acordó Pues que la
activaría y que entraría en marcha para
supervisar la situación Allí va a enviar
una comisión a Perú para que Converse
con los diferentes actores políticos
allí en Lima para conocer la situación y
hacer una evaluación
em ha habido muchas críticas tanto en
Perú como fuera de Perú por este pedido
que hace el presidente porque justamente
eh se habla de una
vulneración de una herramienta que tiene
el gobierno peruano donde el presidente
tal vez la estaría utilizando de la
forma menos apropiada para este tipo de
situaciones su impresión José Carlos
sobre esta activación de la carta y la
llegada de esta comisión que llegará a
Perú en los próximos días
Bueno creo que es algo llamativo porque
quien suele pedir este tipo de cosas
suele ser la oposición es decir suele
ser aquel que se siente más debilitado y
creo que la principal debilidad del
presidente Castillo tiene que ver con la
acorralamiento judicial que
reitero tiene pruebas contundentes no es
algo arbitrario como él lo quiere
presentar de hecho en las últimas horas
se ha se ha
corregido una una decisión judicial que
le daba una medida restrictiva o una
familiar del presidente como para
mostrar de nuevo que esta este acoso o
este esta persecución a la que él se
refiere carece de todos sustento y los
segundos que creo que la oea va a tener
que escuchar a todos los actores Y es
ahí donde va a tomar nota No sólo de las
de las cosas de corrupción que estamos
mencionando sino también de una relación
oscila hacia la prensa de una de un
manejo arbitrario el poder básicamente
con una agenda que tiene como el centro
la sobrevivencia removiendo alto
funcionarios como había mencionado y del
uso del poder incluso para protegerse
Las investigaciones hay algunas
grabaciones de un allanamiento por parte
de la fiscalía que han desaparecido en
fin de muchísimas cosas va a tener que
Tomar
nota esta misión en consecuencia también
puede terminar siendo algo que que sea
un tiro por la culata y finalmente por
mucha mesa de diálogo que haya creo que
la realidad siempre va a terminar
imponiéndose como pasó del año 2000 con
la caída del gobierno Alberto fujimori
Elizabeth se puede confiar en el buen
desarrollo de esta comisión allí en Perú
que todas las partes
involucradas a nivel político vayan a
dar sus versiones de los hechos o puede
haber algún sector que diga no quiero
participar porque el llamado a esta
comisión y A esta carta democrática es
irregular esto no procede nosotros no
participamos Y esto que genere otro
problema
no yo creo en realidad de que aquí he
escuchado por lo menos por lo que he
podido estar al tanto de las posiciones
tanto de los poderes del estado como
diversas instancias y organizaciones de
la sociedad civil están pues muy
dispuestos Más bien a contribuir y a
colaborar con esta comisión de alto
nivel porque como bien dice José Carlos
aquí de lo que se trata es de dar cuenta
de que los actos que se han venido
tomándose han venido dando a nivel tanto
judicial como a nivel del Congreso son
actos que están amparados en la
Constitución y cuyos procedimientos ya
están debidamente regulados no solamente
en la carta constitucional sino en el
reglamento del Congreso y en cuanto a la
fiscal ella está cumpliendo con su
función constitucional y sus
competencias conforme la habilita
también su Ley Orgánica Entonces no se
está saliendo del marco constitucional
aquí y y sirve al contrario sirve para
que se tome cuenta de la Real situación
sobre todo de la situación de la
libertad de expresión en nuestro país de
la libertad de prensa que muchas veces
se ven hechas de lado no cuando ellos
dan una conferencia de prensa y no
invitan a la prensa nacional como la
última conferencia que se realizó donde
solamente invitaron a la prensa
internacional entonces este tipo de
comportamientos estoy segura que
justamente las instituciones van a dar a
conocer para que puedan también tomar
conocimiento de esto y puedan elaborar
Pues un informe acorde a la realidad y
no acorde a la pretensión que
posiblemente sea del señor que él cree
que podría el organismo ampararlo estar
digamos conforme con su actuación y lo
que quizás pretendiera es que se pudiera
dar ese último escenario como es el de
sacar al Perú de la organización no
suspenderlo temporalmente y yo pienso
que esa podría ser una pretensión para
impulsar su asamblea Constituyente ojalá
me equivoqué y no sea así es un
escenario también posible en el momento
todos los escenarios son posibles
Elizabeth José Carlos también ha habido
muchas críticas sobre este organismo
continental precisamente una de las
críticas vino por parte del Congreso
peruano que está liderado por José
Daniel Williams quien envió una carta a
la Organización de Estados Americanos
expresando su preocupación por el uso
que el presidente Castillo le está dando
a este mecanismo A esta carta
democrática para ellos o por lo menos el
punto de vista de Williams es que lo
está haciendo para encubrir y
obstaculizar estas seis investigaciones
penales que hay en su contra y también
impedir entre las críticas que hemos
hecho acá
ese balance de ese contrapeso de las
instituciones y y de las garantías de la
institucionalidad en Perú José Carlos
entonces allí desde Perú está bien visto
que llegue la oea es decir se Confía en
la discreción de la oea para el manejo
de esta situación teniendo los
antecedentes de Nicaragua de Venezuela y
de Bolivia vecino de ustedes donde han
sido muy controvertido el papel que ha
jugado la oe allí confían en lo que la
oea puede hacer allí
bueno ha habido una una recepción mixta
diría un sector de la oposición la
verdad lo ha criticado creo que la carta
de Williams va en ese sentido
creo que las las como lo comentaba
Elizabeth las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil Y algunos entes del
Estado están más que dispuestas a dar su
versión de lo que está pasando en el
Perú y Creo yo que la verdad la sociedad
civil y la oposición harían bien en dar
toda la información y en Mostrar lo que
realmente está pasando en el país No yo
no creo que
yo no creo que digamos la realidad sea
como la que pinte el presidente Castillo
gente castillo y en consecuencia hay que
dar sustento a eso
y y creo que hay que recibir con con
mucha expectativa lo que se puede hacer
con la Obviamente con la con el
escepticismo de haber visto el
comportamiento de otro organismo en
otros espacios y creo que ahí lo clave
va a ser conocer la composición de esta
delegación que que venga en los próximos
días que hay Elizabeth de la población
de los peruanos hemos visto los
esfuerzos de la oposición y el congreso
por llevar a cabo y adelante estas
vacancias pues las votaciones pues no
logran su cometido precisamente por lo
que usted explicaba porque está
atomizada la votación allí en el
congreso Pero qué hay de los ciudadanos
porque también vemos llamados por
ejemplo de la Iglesia Católica peruana
de pedirle al presidente que renuncie
esta falta de acción por parte de las
instituciones del Congreso que no logran
este cometido
puede llevar a desencadenar en
manifestaciones protestas inestabilidad
social y digamos lo de una manera un
poco más cruda la ira de los peruanos
por la necesidad de tener un país
estable
Bueno siempre es un escenario posible la
reacción social definitivamente porque
estamos ante una como bien dice es una
inacción por parte de del Congreso de la
República quien ha tenido diversas
ocasiones para poder validar sus
competencias constitucionales en cuanto
a control político y estas herramientas
para darle una crisis
una salida a la crisis de forma
constitucional
no quiero hablar por todos los
congresistas pero lamentablemente tienes
ahí pues una mayoría que está compuesta
sobre todo por las fuerzas de izquierda
que no permiten dejar avanzar la agenda
política
urgente para solucionar esta crisis de
la mano a sus aliados que lo encontramos
Pues en diversos partidos
Lamentablemente y que le restan Pues
esta votación que se necesita para una
salida democrática y el problema es ese
y creo que y la Definitivamente hay un
gran porcentaje de acuerdo a las
encuestas últimas de rechazo al gobierno
también hay un porcentaje que no está de
acuerdo con el actor del Congreso pero
la gran mayoría de peruanos quiere salir
de esta crisis y quiere que de una vez
por todas el congreso actúe dándole fin
a esta crisis con una vacancia o una
acusación constitucional esos son otros
de los escenarios posibles José Carlos
Elizabeth vamos llegando ya el bloque
final para terminar el programa y quiero
que empecemos a hacer las conclusiones
porque creo que hay varios temas para
abordar sobre esta crisis política
José Carlos comenzó con usted qué bien
entonces ahora para Perú siempre lo digo
ya el frase de oro aquí en el programa
no tenemos la bola de cristal para saber
el futuro de lo que va a pasar con los
temas que analizamos aquí en el debate
Pero a qué escenario puede llegar Perú
después de la visita de esta comisión de
la Organización de Estados Americanos
Qué puede pasar en este país como
mira y yo diría que si seguimos en la
misma situación hasta fin de año es
decir con un congreso atado con un
congreso que no llega a encontrar una
salida y creo que de ir por algunas de
las opciones distintas a la vacancia ese
será el camino por lo porque son
procedimientos largos
pues ya tendríamos que esperar mucho más
los meses de verano entre enero y marzo
en Perú por el verano de esta región
suelen ser más lentos De hecho hay un
receso parlamentario En consecuencia yo
pensaría que si no se resuelve la crisis
con algún desenlace hasta finales de año
quizás recién hacia mediados del próximo
año podamos ver alguna salida de otra
manera Vamos a continuar en esta
situación y han pasado precisamente hoy
se cumplen dos semanas desde la que
desde que la fiscal presentó toda la
documentación y hemos conseguido en lo
mismo básicamente hay algunos juegos
artificiales como lo de la misión de la
oea pero no hay un desenlace en el
Horizonte cercano pienso yo sí es decir
esta agónica crisis podría prolongarse
por lo menos hasta después de el verano
austral es decir después del mes de
marzo según las palabras de José Carlos
Elizabeth para el cierre del programa su
conclusión
Sí bueno Lamentablemente son procesos
largos
el de vacancia presidencial y en la
acusación constitucional
Lamentablemente así van a exceder al año
hay que hay que decirlo con todas sus
letras al no ser que por esas cosas del
milagro de un milagro así divino desde
fecha de octubre acá estamos en época
del Señor de los milagros Quizás El
Milagro morado sea que lo pongan en
agenda y que la prioricen sobre toda la
la agenda política que tiene el congreso
lo cual lo dudo y Y lamentablemente pues
podemos llevar acá a un levantamiento
inclusive en las regiones a mí me
preocupa muchísimo sobre todo la lectura
de la población en las regiones que la
estamos dejando de lado No justamente
son las que están más golpeadas a raíz
de la pandemia y las más necesitadas en
este momento de una de una acción pronta
en cuanto a gestión pública gestión de
gobierno que hasta este momento no llega
entonces a mí sí me preocupa cualquier
reacción del interior respecto a esta
crisis que pueda hacer pues contrario a
lo que se no una salida democrática pues
es otro capítulo más en esta crisis
interminable en Perú Seguiremos atentos
a lo que ocurra allí a los hechos que
acontezcan en este país suramericano
siguiéndole el pulso al acontecer
político allí a José Carlos y Elizabeth
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros a ustedes Muchas gracias por la
sintonía el día de hoy la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera sigan comentando a través
de las redes sociales sigan con France
[Música]